In this video I will prove
to you that the limit as
x approaches 0 of sine of
x over x is equal to 1.
But before I do that, before I
break into trigonometry, I'm
going to go over another
aspect of limits.
And that's the squeeze theorem.
Because once you understand
what the squeeze theorem is,
we can use the squeeze
theorem to prove this.
It's actually a pretty involved
explanation, but I think you'll
find it pretty neat and
satisfying if you get it.
If you don't get it, maybe you
just want to memorize this.
Because that's a very useful
limit to know later on when
we take the derivatives
of trig functions.
So what's the squeeze theorem?
The squeeze theorem is
my favorite theorem in
mathematics, possibly because
it has the word squeeze in it.
Squeeze theorem.
And when you read it in a
calculus book it looks
all complicated.
I don't know when you read
it, in a calculus book or
in a precalculus book.
It looks all complicated,
but what it's saying is
frankly pretty obvious.
Let me give you an example.
If I told you that I
always-- so Sal always
eats more than Umama.
Umama is my wife.
If I told you that this
is true, Sal always
eats more than Umama.
And I were also to say that Sal
always eats less than-- I don't
know, let me make up a
fictional character--
than Bill.
So on any given day-- let's
say this is in a given day.
Sal always eats more than Umama
in any given day, and Sal
always eats less than
Bill on any given day.
Now if I were tell you that on
Tuesday Umama ate 300 calories
and on Tuesday Bill
ate 300 calories.
So my question to you is, how
many calories did Sal eat,
or did I eat, on Tuesday?
Well I always eat more than
Umama-- well, more than or
equal to Umama-- and I always
eat less than or equal to Bill.
So then on Tuesday, I must
have eaten 300 calories.
So this is the gist of the
squeeze theorem, and I'll do
a little bit more formally.
But it's essentially saying, if
I'm always greater than one
thing and I'm always less than
another thing and at some point
those two things are equal,
well then I must be equal
to whatever those two
things are equal to.
I've kind of been squeezed
in between them.
I'm always in between Umama and
Bill, and if they're at the
exact same point on
Tuesday, then I must be at
that point as well.
Or at least I must approach it.
So let me write it
in math terms.
So all it says is that, over
some domain, if I say that,
let's say that g of x is less
than or equal to f of x, which
is less than or equal to
h of x over some domain.
And we also know that the limit
of g of x as x approaches a is
equal to some limit, capital L,
and we also know that the limit
as x approaches a of h of x
also equals L, then the squeeze
theorem tells us-- and I'm not
going to prove that right
here, but it's good to just
understand what the squeeze
theorem is-- the squeeze
theorem tells us then the limit
as x approaches a of f of x
must also be equal to L.
And this is the same thing.
This is example where f of x,
this could be how much Sal eats
in a day, this could be how
much Umama eats in a
day, this is Bill.
So I always eat more than
Umama or less than Bill.
And then on Tuesday, you could
say a is Tuesday, if Umama had
300 calories and Bill had 300
calories, then I also had
to eat 300 calories.
Let me let me graph
that for you.
Let me graph that, and I'll
do it in a different color.
Squeeze theorem.
OK, so let's draw the
point a comma L.
The point a comma L.
Let's say this is a, that's
the point that we care
about. a, and this is L.
And we know, g of x, that's
the lower function, right?
So let's say that this
green thing right
here, this is g of x.
So this is my g of x.
And we know that as g of x
approaches-- so the g of x
could look something
like that, right?
And we know that the limit
as x approaches a of
g of x is equal to L.
So that's right there.
So this is g of x.
That's g of x.
Let me do h of x in
a different color.
So now h of x could look
something like this.
Like that.
So that's h of x.
And we also know that the limit
as x approaches a of h of x --
let's see, this is the
function of x axis.
So you can call it h of
x, g of x, or f of x.
That's just the dependent
access, and this is the x-axis.
So once again, the limit as x
approaches a of h of x, well
at that point right there,
h of a is equal to L.
Or at least the limit
is equal to that.
And none of these functions
actually have to even be
defined at a, as long as these
limits, this limit exists
and this limit exists.
And that's also an important
thing to keep in mind.
So what does this tell us?
f of x is always greater
than this green function.
It's always less
than h of x, right?
So any f of x I draw,
it would have to be in
between those two, right?
So no matter how I draw it, if
I were to draw a function,
it's bounded by those two
functions just by definition.
So it has to go
through that point.
Or at least it has to
approach that point.
Maybe it's not defined at that
point, but the limit as we
approach a of f of x also
has to be at point L.
And maybe f of x doesn't have
to be defined right there, but
the limit as we approach
it is going to be L.
And hopefully that makes a
little bit of sense, and
hopefully my calories
example made a little
bit of sense to you.
So let's keep that in
the back of our mind,
the squeeze theorem.
And now we will use that to
prove that the limit as x
approaches 0 of sine of
x over x is equal to 1.
And I want to do that,
one, because this is
a super useful limit.
And then the other thing is,
sometimes you learn the squeeze
theorem, you're like, oh, well
that's obvious but
when is it useful?
And we'll see.
Actually I'm going to do it in
the next video, since we're
already pushing 8 minutes.
But we'll see in the next video
that the squeeze theorem is
tremendously useful when
we're trying to prove this.
I will see you in
the next video.